I did terrible things turned on rub
capture Winterfell killed those boys
what those boys they were bran and
Rickon they were your brothers you've
known them since they were born without
me
only what they were tell me why bran and
Rickon should be gone while you still
breathe the air tell me to my face Theon
tell me that they warned your brothers
bran and Rickon hi I'm Alfie Allen and
I'm here to talk about Game of Thrones
yeah hits talk about Game of Thrones
Season five DVD release yeah I mean he's
coming one of the most ever-changing
characters on the show you know he's
kind of gone from I guess Richard Madden
Robb Stark's or trusted sidekick and
then he kind of went on his own I guess
mission to become prince king of the
salt throne and pike and now but I mean
it weirdly you know it's kind of ironic
that he um he set out on this journey to
become so king of Pike and now he was a
slave essentially his whole life anyway
and then goes off to try and sort become
his power figure and then he becomes a
slave again in a way way worse state but
I guess one of the main changes that's
happened to him as being completely
appropriate in my in my opinion because
you know I'm talking about it's always a
difficult issue to tackle this one um
but yeah he needed that he couldn't
neither taken away from him but he had
no real point of authority anywhere in
his life and except for being in the
bedroom so I have that take taken away
from I thought was very appropriate and
relevant he's kind of one of the most
human characters on the show you know he
makes mistakes and that's the universal
thing that we can all relate to
we all make mistakes and
think he's not really a good a good or a
body in that respect I did a new by the
torture aspect of it I knew about the I
did a play called Equus and it was very
intense a role to play and I think Dave
and Dan knew that once I could so I
guess I could I could handle a role like
that then I would be the right person
for this for this role but I knew about
the torch respect I knew about the weak
aspect but I didn't know about I didn't
know that they were gonna because in the
books reek is just the name of his
former slave and I think he dies in the
Battle of all the burning of Winterfell
and so then I saw take for the name or
the new role of weak from the former
slave and now I become the new slave as
an actor it's always nice to have a
beginning middle and end but I think in
the golden age of television that we are
now in you know things have to be so
closely guarded and secrets have to be
very carefully handled that you can you
know I guess essentially I dunno a kind
of end game but but there's many things
that can happen in between though there
could certainly tell you change that
I was worried I mean I'm just happy to
be in part lashauwn's that are live in
the show but there was a point when I
think at the end of season two I was
asking Dave and Dan completely
tactlessly whether I was going to be
alive or dead and they were never really
giving me a straight answer and then I
got scripts given to me there was a fake
script I didn't those fake scripts at
the time but I it was a when I saw the
back of the winter film and I come out
and I give my rousing speech that I get
knocked over the head in the real one
but in the fake script bran came out on
the back of Hodor and stabbed me in the
heart and says this is my Winterfell not
yours and and I thought it was a good
way to go like I did I mean I'm sure I'd
be crying two or three years down the
line just to see how much for juggernaut
the show become I wasn't a part of
anymore but I mean it always really was
a juggernaut then but it's um it's it
was it was kind of funny to have that
prank played on me and then I'm they
called me off on like so how would you
feel about a how would you feel about
being in the next series knows that oh
my god that'd be amazing like okay cool
how would you feel about being as on
yeah kind of up for that I don't mind in
what context no like while you'd be a
zombie would like absolutely no dialogue
whatsoever you just wouldn't speak at
all you just be standing there as a
zombie I was like you having me on and
so thankfully it was a joke um but yeah
I guess guess I am still worried about
him dying but but I've got a mortgage to
pay so please keep me alive
Catelyn Stark mm-hmm
because she is an amazing woman and
probably one of the most compassionate
characters in the show phreak phreak
course really yeah I'm filming on it
definitely reat deserves to be on the
Iron Throne because he's been through so
much hardships and you know he would be
tender to his people because no one has
been tended to him for his whole life so
he would he would treat the people as
his own because he's been through so
much hardships and he would be tender to
his own people yeah